to make money on social media you have
to know how to sell but most people just
come off an authentic or straight up
sleazy but in this video chalene Johnson
shares her five-step framework to sell
using Instagram stories while
maintaining authenticity and building a
community so the first thing you want to
do is like identify with the problem so
let people decide do you have this
problem or not so you can see in this
particular example 91 of my audience
said yeah I have this problem too cool
I've just done a service to the nine
percent of my audience who says like no
I don't I don't have that problem I've
done them a favor I said you can tap buy
now they know I don't have this problem
I'm not going to watch her stories and
basically the story that I'm describing
here is I'm saying does anyone else deal
with this where like because of my ADHD
if I put something away and I can't see
it I don't know that I own it it's gone
in my mind it's like it's gone I'll
never see it again so like for leggings
right so workout tights whatever you
want to call them your Lululemon tights
right I have so many of those in
multiple I had like 10 pairs of pink
because I would fold them and put them
away and I I would forget that I had a
pink pair and I would buy another pink
pair and so I asked people do you have
that problem the next slide of my story
is relate to the problem and so I
explained to people like what is my
solution I explained to people like what
why that how that happens to me out of
sight out of mind then what I'm gonna do
in my third story slide is show people
like I solved the problem
I solved the problem now think about
this for a second
don't just think about this problem
think about something that you
have solved a problem like I don't I
don't know what it is maybe you know
you're trying to sell your used car
maybe you uh have a difficult time
getting your kid to get in the bath that
night don't think about the product that
you sell I don't sell what I'm about to
show you
but I want you to get in the habit
in the habit of this template because if
this template is what people are
expecting and they love it and they're
and they can't wait for more than when
you do from time to time sprinkle in
something that you actually sell you
know that that's yours it feels you're
not selling you're just explaining
people know I don't sell towel racks
people know
you don't sell a system to get your kid
in the bathtub at night you know so it
that builds like a um a real reciprocity
like people are like I love that you're
always like sharing these things
then the so that was the third part the
fourth part
let me see if I can forward my slides
the fourth part is that then tell people
not to click on a link see I didn't put
a link up there
I said comment the word or the phrase
shop Amazon
now you can sort through your responses
in your DMs you can search the word
Amazon and then anyone who's commented
that phrase I can just copy and paste my
Amazon favorites or
I can copy and paste this link
um this but more importantly I can have
a conversation great examples I I saw
this gal she's in network marketing and
I saw one of her posts couple days ago
and um in the post
she this is so funny this is so girls in
the post she looks adorable she looks
amazing not just adorable she looked
amazing like body rocking
hottie body and she talked about the
program that she did to get these this
amazing transformation right she had
lost like I forget what it was like
something like eight pounds in less than
two months and her body was just like
amazing she had had a baby so she she
shared the name of the program how many
days per week she did it
um how to get access to it she put
clicked the link in my bio put all the
information
she had a super cute Peach shiny
leggings and matching Peach tennis shoes
and didn't mention those
guess what every freaking Comet was
what do you think ladies know what was
every question
yeah where'd you get your leggings
where'd you get your shoes not one
person asked how did you lose the weight
because she already told them
I would have recommend you do that post
in reverse
I would have done that post and said
um I would have never been able to rock
these aloe shiny leggings that I got for
49 from aloe and my cute matching Nike
uh 270 Max shoes had I not lost eight
pounds in the last seven weeks from an
online program that rocked my world
now where have I created the Curiosity
give them all the information that you
don't want them to ask about and just
save some of this other stuff the stuff
that you actually want them to have a
conversation with you about save some of
that for more content like this go to
ideatoincome.tips there's a link down in
the description and we'll see you guys
in the next video